and now for something completely
different
do you mind doing a uh a bit of a meme
review in the spirit of the great the
powerful pewdiepie
let's say 1 to 11 just go over a few
documents print it out we can try let's
try this
i present to you document
numero uno
okay
vladimi paler discovers
marshmallows
that's not bad
so
you get it because uh yes are you
failing things yes
i know three whatever
oh that's not very good
this is uh
grounded in some engineering
some history
uh yeah give us an eight out of ten
what do you think about nuclear power
i'm in favor of nuclear power i think
it's uh
i i in a place that is not subject to
extreme natural disasters i think it's a
nuclear power is a great way to generate
uh electricity
um i i don't think we should be shutting
down nuclear power stations
yeah but what about chernobyl
exactly um
so
[Music]
uh i think i think people there's like a
lot of fear of radiation and stuff um
and it's
i guess the problem is like a lot of
people just don't
underst
they didn't study
engineering or physics so they don't
it's just the word radiation just sounds
scary you know so they don't they ha
they can't calibrate what radiation
means
um
but radiation is much less dangerous
than
than you'd think
so
um
like for example fukushima you know um
when the fukushima problem happened uh
to the tsunami the
i got people in california asking me if
they should worry about radiation
from fukushima i'm like
definitely not not even slightly not at
all that is crazy
um
and
just to
show like look
this is how
like the dangers is so much overplayed
compared to what what it really is that
i actually flew to fukushima
and i actually i donated a
a solar power system for water treatment
plant and uh
and and i made a point of
eating locally grown vegetables
on tv
in fukushima
like
i'm still alive okay
so it's not even at the risk of these
events is low but the impact of them is
impact is greatly exaggerated it's it's
just human nature
it's people people don't know what
radiation is like i've had people ask me
like what about radiation from cell
phones according to causing brain cancer
i'm like when you say radiation do you
mean photons or particles then like that
i don't know what what do you mean
protons particles so do you mean
uh
let's say photons what
what frequency or wavelength and they're
like no i have no idea um like do you
know that everything's radiating all the
time
like what do you mean like yeah
everything's radiating all the time
photons are being emitted
by all objects all the time basically so
um
and if you want to know what it's it's
what it means to stand in front of
nuclear fire
go outside
the sun is a gigantic
you know thermonuclear
reactor that you're staring right at it
are you still alive yes okay amazing
yeah i guess radiation is one of the
words that can be used as a tool to to
fear monger by certain people that's it
and i think people just don't understand
so that's the way to fight that uh that
fear i suppose is to understand this to
learn
yeah just say like okay how many people
have actually died from nuclear
accidents it's like practically nothing
and
uh say how many people have died from
you know coal
plants and it's a very big number
so
like obviously we should not be
starting up coal plants and shutting
down nuclear plants just doesn't make
any sense
at all
coal plants like i don't know 100 to a
thousand times worse for for health than
nuclear power plants
uh you want to go to the next one
it's really bad
it's uh that uh
90 180 and 360 degrees everybody loves
the math nobody gives a [ __ ] about 270.
it's not super funny
yeah i don't like two or three yeah um
this is not a you know
lol situation
[Laughter]
uh that was pretty good the united
states oscillating between establishing
and destroying dictatorships it's like a
metro is that a match yeah
yeah yeah it's a on a 7 out of 10. it's
kind of true oh yeah this is uh
this is kind of personal for me next one
oh man this is leica yeah well no is
this or it's like referring to like or
something as like as like
a husband husband yeah yeah hello yes
this is dog your wife was launched into
space and then the last one
is him with his eyes closed and a bottle
of vodka
yeah like it didn't come back no
they don't tell you the full story of
you know what what the love the impact
they had in the loved ones yeah true
that one gets an 11 for me
oh yeah it just keeps going
on the russian theme
first man in space
nobody cares first man on the moon well
i think people do care no i know but um
there is uruguay gardens names will
will be
forever in history i think there is
something special about
placing like
stepping foot onto another totally
foreign land
it's it's not the journey like uh people
that explored the oceans it's not as
important to explore the oceans is to
land on a whole new continent
yeah this is about you
oh yeah i'd love to get your comment on
this elon musk
after sending 6.6 billion dollars to the
u.n to end world hunger
you have three hours
um you know i mean obviously 6 billion
is not going to end well to hunger so
um
so
i mean the reality is at this point the
world is producing uh
far more food than it can really consume
like we don't have a caloric uh
constraint to this point so where there
is hunger it is
uh almost always due to um
it's like like civil war or strife or
some like um
it's it's not a thing that is
it's extremely rare for it to be just a
matter of like
like lack of money it's like
you know it's like some there's a civil
war in some some country and and like
one part of the country's literally
trying to starve the other part of the
country um
so it's much more complex than something
that money could solve it's politics
geopolitics it's
it's
a lot of things it's human nature it's
governments it's monies monetary systems
all that kind of stuff
yeah food is extremely cheap uh these
days it's like it's
um
i mean the u.s at this point um
you know among low-income families
obesity is actually another problem it's
not
like obviously it's not hunger it's it's
like too much you know too many calories
uh so
it's not that nobody's hungry hungry
anywhere it's just it's just this is uh
not not a simple matter of adding money
and solving it
what do you think that one gets
just kidding
two
this is going after empires world uh
where did you get those artifacts the
british museum
shout out to
monty python we found them
yeah
the british museum is it's pretty great
i mean yeah it admittedly britain did
take uh these historical artifacts from
all around the world and put them in
london but uh you know it it's not like
people can't go see them uh so it is
like a convenient place to see these uh
ancient artifacts is is london for
you know for a large segment of the
world
so i think you know on balance the
british museum is a net good
although i'm sure a lot of countries
argue about that yeah
it's like you want to make these
historical artifacts accessible to as
many people as possible
and the british museum
i think does a good job of that
even if there's a darker aspect to like
the history of empire in general
whatever the empire is
however things were done
this it is the history that happened you
can't sort of erase that history
unfortunately you could just become
better in the future
that's the point
yeah i mean
it's like well how how are we gonna
pass moral judgment on these these
things like it's like if you uh
you know uh
if one is going to judge say the russian
empire you've got to judge you know what
everyone was doing at the time and how
were the british relative to everyone
um
and i think they would brush would
actually get like a relatively good
grade relatively good grade not in
absolute terms but compared to
what everyone else was doing um
they were not the worst
like i said you gotta look at these
things in the context of the history at
the time um and say what what were the
alternatives and what are you comparing
it against yes and i'd
i do not think it would be the case that
um
britain would get a uh
a bad grade in in when looking at
history at the time you know if you
judge
history from
you know
from
what is morally acceptable today you
basically are going to give everyone a
failing grade yeah i'm not clear it's
not i don't think anyone would get a
passing grade um
in in their morality uh of like you go
back 300 years ago like who's getting a
passing grade
basically no one
and we might not get a passing grade
from generations but uh they come after
us
uh what does that one get
uh
sure uh success seven
for the monty python maybe i always love
magic python they're great
uh michael bryan and the quest of holy
grail are incredible yeah yeah yeah
those serious eyebrows
impressions
like you know how important is facial
hair to great leadership
well you got a new haircut is that is
that is this how does that affect your
leadership
i i don't know hopefully not
it doesn't um
yeah the second is no one
there is no one competing with friends i
have no one too those are like epic
eyebrows
so sure
that's ridiculous six or seven i don't
know uh i like this like shakespearean
analysis of memes
he had a flair for drama as well
like you know
showmanship yeah yeah it must come from
the eyebrows all right um
invention great engineering look what i
invented yeah that's the best thing
since ripped up bread yeah cause they
invented they're just
sliced bread am i just explaining memes
at this point
this is what my life has become
um
a meme
like you know like a scribe that like
runs around with the kings and just like
writes down
memes
i mean when was a cheeseburger invented
that's like an epic invention yeah like
like wow
you know
that was versus just like a burger or a
burger i guess a burger in general it's
like you know um
then there's like what is a burger
what's what's a sandwich and then you
start getting it's a pizza sandwich and
what is the original
it's it's it gets into an ontology
argument yeah but everybody knows like
if you order like a burger or
cheeseburger whatever you like you get
like you know tomato and some lettuce
and onions and whatever and you know
mayor and ketchup and mustard it's like
epic
yeah but i'm sure they've had bread and
meat separately for a long time and it
was kind of a burger on the same plate
but somebody who actually combined them
into the same thing
and yeah you bite it and hold it make
makes it convenient it's a materials
problem like your hands don't get
dirty and whatever yeah it's brilliant
well that is not what i would have
guessed
but everyone knows like you you like if
you order a cheeseburger you know what
you're getting you know it's not like
some obtuse like i wonder what i'll get
you know um you know fries are
i mean
great i mean they're the devil but fries
are awesome um and uh
yeah
pizza is incredible
food innovation doesn't get enough love
yeah i guess is what we're getting at
it's great um
uh what about the uh matthew mcconaughey
austinite here uh president kennedy do
you know how to put men on the moon yet
nasa no president kennedy
be a lot cooler if you did
pretty much
sure six six or seven i suppose
it's the last one
that's funny
someone drew a bunch of dicks all over
the walls sistine chapel boys bathroom
sure i'll give it nine it's super it's
really true
all right this is our highest ranking
meme for today
i mean it's true like how do they get
away with that
lots of nakedness
i mean dick pics are
i mean just something throughout history
uh as long as people can draw things
there's been a dick pic it's
a staple of human history it's a staple
consistent throughout human history
you